ah
allergy season you understand
[Music]
all right cocaine back so cocaine I'm
gonna give you the actual plot of
cocaine back some blow is jettisoned
from a plane over a park so these drug
Runners are looking for the snow a cop
is looking for them for good measure
there's a mom looking for her two kids
who decided to go gallivanting in the
park that day oh very dangerous because
yes there is a coked out bear who found
the stash and now the bear is on a
rampage
fish this is the kind of movie that
makes me feel like I've I've gone mad
I've gone insane you can find my sanity
down the precipice of Madness some
people coming out of the movie seem to
be enjoying it I'm glad
this movie is ass though this movie had
me spending time with these pockets of
human characters on their own little
arcs and never got me to give a [__]
about them you gotta care about the
human characters otherwise it doesn't
feel like they're any Stakes but maybe
we're here to watch the bear tear people
apart have some fun Gore comedy with our
humans otherwise known as cannon fodder
that was even unfulfilling this movie is
a dark horror comedy
I'm saying that going off the trailer
because the trailer made it look that
way this movie looks like it tried to be
that there were quite a few moments in
this movie where I was like I get what
you were going for I mean in that same
way when you're watching baseball you
see someone just swing their ass off and
miss the ball you're like well you were
trying for a home run
doesn't mean it happened the thing is
for the movie trying to be a horror or
Gore comedy it was just never funny Gore
can be funny I mean there's a scene in
this movie where someone accidentally
gets shot in the head accidentally
shooting someone in the face can be
funny Pulp Fiction is a testament to
that I knew something was very wrong
early in the film well 20 minutes into
the film because I was like oh my God
nothing's happening how long would we've
only been here for 20 minutes I thought
that was an hour but all in all it felt
like Lieutenant Commander Data I know
I've used this comparison before but I
don't feel I use it often enough so I'm
gonna use it again Star Trek the Next
Generation Lieutenant Commander Data he
would try to do poetry or comedy it just
didn't land the pieces were there but it
lacked that human element that landed
with the audience everyone's like oh God
when's this gonna be over that's what it
felt like in this movie when someone
lost a limb or died and it's clearly
constructed in a way that's supposed to
make the audience laugh but it doesn't
it's almost like it's accidentally Grade
B Grade B Gore when purposefully done to
be so can be fun fun absolutely when
it's accidentally Grade B just comes
across a sad plot twist cocaine bear
never tried to be funny
it would almost make it worse
or make it Immortal okay so it's not
funny is it scary or intense no to both
of those the editing was choppy and
clunky as [__] as well one scene that
stands out in particular is they're
walking and someone's like oh my gosh
the bear might be in there remember that
body we saw back there and then it does
a flashback of them tripping over a body
and then flashes here almost felt like
the scene where they tripped over her
body was cut out and then right before
final cut someone's like oh God they
mentioned the body we cut out with all
right we'll just have this awkward
flashback show him trip over about it
and go back that works maybe it did
maybe it was the best we could do but
the movie doesn't now we do get it a
movie with a poster like that is not a
movie to take too seriously please
understand this is not me trying to take
a movie too seriously it's just me
asking that a movie live up to its own
poster this movie's not that fun it's at
this point where I'm like I'm sizing up
my writing based on what would land best
I'm gonna go ahead and go with the
probably be a better time if you're well
not drunk but on substances that I don't
want to get demonetized you know what
I'm alluding to yeah no it's a party all
right so cocaine bear have you seen it
what did you think about it do you feel
like you've gone mad as mad as I have or
did you like the movie whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
foreign